>> Sean: THE DESTROYER HAVE
BEEN TRUMP MEDIAN LEVEL
DEMOCRATS WILL DO ANYTHING TO
DETRACT FROM THE PRESIDENT'S
SUCCESSES AND THEY ARE NUMEROUS.
A NEW GALLUP POLL CALLED SURVEY
SATISFACTION WITH THE U.S.
DIRECTION AND A 12 YEAR HIGH.
NUMBERS DON'T LIE.
FACTS DON'T LIE.
HERE WITH REACTION, THE AUTHOR
OF THE NEW BOOK IT CHRONICLES
THE PRESIDENT'S SUCCESS IN A
LITTLE OVER 500 DAYS.
IT IS CALLED "TRANSAMERICA: THE
TRUTH ABOUT OUR NATION'S GREAT
COMEBACK."
Amazon.com, BOOKSTORES
EVERYWHERE.
FORMER SPEAKER THE HOUSE,
NEWT GINGRICH.
LET'S GO TO WHAT WAS UNFOLDING
INVESTIGATORS IN THE CASE AND AT
LEAST FIVE OF THEM, THE LEAD
GUYS, HATED TRUMP AND LIGHT
HILLARY CLINTON.
I MEAN, HOW COULD ANY
INVESTIGATION LIKE THAT IN THE
SAME PEOPLE GOT INVOLVED IN THE
TRUMP-RUSSIA PROBE.
IMMEDIATELY THEREAFTER.
HOW COULD THERE BE ANY
LEGITIMACY TO MUELLER'S CASE IF
THAT'S THE ORIGINS OF THIS.
>> LOCAL, I DON'T THINK THERE IS
ANY LEGITIMACY AND I THINK IT
GOES BACK TO SOMETHING THAT WE
NEED TO HAVE A DEEPER NATIONAL
DEBATE ABOUT.
THERE REALLY IS A DEEP STATE.
THAT DEEP STATE IN THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT GAVE 97% OF ITS
DONATIONS IN 2016 TO
HILLARY CLINTON.
THE LANGUAGE THEY USE.
I MEAN, IF YOU IMAGINE A
GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEE WHO USE THE
SAME LANGUAGE ABOUT
AFRICAN-AMERICANS OR LATINOS OR
JEWISH AMERICANS ARE MUSLIM
AMERICANS THAT THEY USE IN SOME
OF THOSE QUOTES, ABOUT TRUMP
SUPPORTERS, YOU WOULD HAVE
SCREAMS TO HIGH HEAVEN.
IT'S CLEAR THAT YOU HAD AN
ATTITUDE AT THE VERY SENIOR
LEVELS, NOT DOWN AT THE LOCAL
CASEWORKER, NOT DOWN AT THE
LOCAL OFFICES, BUT IN THE
WASHINGTON HEADQUARTERS BOTH IN
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND IN
THE FBI, THE SENIOR FIGURES BY
ANY POSSIBLE STANDARD ARE
CORRUPT.
AND THEY CLEARLY WERE OPERATING
ON THE PREMISE THAT HILLARY WAS
GOING TO GET TO BE PRESIDENT AND
THEREFORE ANYTHING THEY SAID OR
DID WAS FINE BECAUSE SHE WOULD
COVER IT UP.
>> Sean: IF THEY DID THEIR
JOB, THEY WOULD'VE SET THE
ENTIRE 2016 ELECTION TO UTTER
CHAOS.
BOTH THEIR ANIMUS, ANIMUS,
ANTIPATHY, DOWNRIGHT HATRED.
WHY ARE YOU LAUGHING?
FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP, AND YOU ARE
RIGHT, AND HIS SUPPORTERS, THE
PEOPLE THAT VOTED.
WHY ARE YOU LAUGHING?
>> IF PEOPLE HAD DONE THEIR JOB,
HILLARY WOULD'VE FACED JAIL TIME
IN 1978 IN '79 WHICH MADE
$98,000 ON A $1,000 INVESTMENT
IN CATTLE FUTURES WITH
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL"
FIGURED OUT WAS A 6 TRILLION TO
ONE IMPOSSIBILITY.
SPENT HER WHOLE CAREER --
"FOX NEWS @ NIGHT" SHOULD WE
CONCLUDE THERE IS NO EQUAL
JUSTICE UNDER THE LAW, EQUAL
APPLICATION OF OUR LAWS, THAT
CLINTON HAS ONE STANDARD THAN
THE REST OF US ARE SCREWED?
>> NO, WE SHOULD CONCLUDE THAT
THE AMERICAN LEFT IS QUITE
COMFORTABLE WITH CORRUPTION
BECAUSE IT SO DEEPLY DESPISES
THE AMERICAN SYSTEM, WHETHER
THAT IS BARACK OBAMA, WHETHER IT
IS THE ATTORNEY GENERAL UNDER
OBAMA, WHETHER IT IS COMEY OR
MUELLER.
ALL OF THESE PEOPLE ARE THE SAME
PEOPLE AND THEY GO BACK FOR OVER
A DECADE.
YOU CAN GO BACK AND FIND THEM
AGAIN AND AGAIN COMING UP IN
WAYS.
>> Sean: THIS IS AN AMERICAN
ELECTION.
WE ARE NOT THE FORMER
SOVIET UNION.
WE ARE NOT VENEZUELA, OR AT
LEAST I DIDN'T THINK SO.
BUT IF THE STANDS AND IT APPEARS
IT DOES, SHOW ME WHERE HILLARY
IS GOING TO GET THE INDICTMENT
SHE DESERVES.
AND WHEN IS THIS WITCH HUNT
GOING TO STOP WHAT IT WAS ALL
PREDICATED ON THE BIGGEST
ANTI-TRUMP WHICH HUNTERS IN THE
WORLD, PROVEN BY THEIR
STATEMENTS.
>> LOOK, FIRST OF ALL, I DON'T
KNOW THAT ANYBODY WHO WAS ON THE
CORRUPTIONS SIDE OF THIS IS
NECESSARILY SAFE.
IT UNRAVELS GRADUALLY AND KEEPS
UNRAVELING.
IT'S GOING TO KEEP UNRAVELING
SOME MORE.
EVERY WEEK THAT GOES BY, WE
LEARN NEW THINGS.
THEY ARE HORRIFYING THINGS, AND
FRANKLY THEY SHOULD REMIND ALL
OF US HOW CLOSE WE CAME TO
LOSING THE COUNTRY.
YOU HAVE BETWEEN OBAMA AND
CLINTON A TOTAL DISREGARD FOR
THE AMERICAN TRADITION, A TOTAL
DISREGARD FOR THE TRUTH, WHETHER
THEY WERE LYING ABOUT BENGHAZI
OR THEY WERE LYING ABOUT
BIN LADEN, OR THEY WERE LYING
ABOUT THE RUSSIANS OR THEY ARE
LYING ABOUT THE CAMPAIGN.
THESE PEOPLE DIDN'T CARE BECAUSE
THEY CAME OUT OF A LEFT-WING
BACKGROUND.
>> Sean: HERE IS MY QUESTION.
HOW DO WE -- I WILL CONCEDE THE
POINT, AND PATIENTS IS NOT MY
GREATEST VIRTUE.
NOT THAT I HAVE A LOT OF GREAT
VIRTUES.
BUT IN ALL SERIOUSNESS THAT I
KNOW THIS IS THE BEGINNING, ARE
YOU CONFIDENT THAT WHAT SHOULD
BE THE EQUAL APPLICATION OF LAWS
ESPECIALLY WITH HILLARY AND
ESPECIALLY -- MUELLER'S TEAM IS
AS CORRUPT AS COMEY'S TEAM WAS
GOING AFTER, INVESTIGATING
CLINTON.
IT IS THE SAME PEOPLE.
IT IS ALL SORTED BY THE SAME
PEOPLE.
IT SHOULD RENDER IT ILLEGITIMATE
IT SHOULD RENDER IT ILLEGITIMAT
ILLEGITIMATE.
>> I BELIEVE THAT PEOPLE WHO
WANT TO PRESERVE THE RULE OF LAW
HAVE TO KEEP THE PRESSURE UP.
AND I VERY MUCH ADMIRE WHAT
SENATOR HATCH WAS DOING TODAY,
WHAT SENATOR GRASSLEY WAS DOING.
I LOOK FORWARD TO CUMBERSOME AND
GOODLATTE TOMORROW.
PEOPLE ARE GETTING AROUSED AND